.
>>> A FORM OF PSYCHOSIS, THAT'S
WHAT INFO WARS FOUNDER ALEX SAYM
BELIEVE EVENTS LIKE THE SANDY
HOOK MASSACRE WERE STAGED.IOIARO
HA N ALL A
CONUHPU T O
LIDIEU NE
SILEIO T WRE OSOFIH OLT TNSSEREH
OHITINEVIVYET TO NGTU A
HOEDE-sTHRTNEEWRES,VEINITNDF SNI
F TH WHRERS T
IXCKONOCTH TS I
TT A PS.RNAS OONAUATE
LFOS T
NK AIOWRER
PAORR F FFTOL,MAE J
ZB RWSSADOF BRIEL.ITISTI W L KTT
TATCRATIT
OUVA R
HE OED,SO
AT TEHE NTIN TMROESMAIO T,ISPAH
ATO ISILOELI EA,ER DUT NGY T RN
LLITIK TNOATOSKINCVEKETYHOIO
NA I IHGHTIADAR LEU
HEYERLO G HEGR
ONSHA>> FSTUGSNO SEN HG,CO HON
T
WISDAFS,, PO JCH DI J,O S THE
,ID OT  RHEHEW'S
TH DNG
YRNDJO PCAUSN A ME IBSSEVEIOPE A
AVNSURLEEM TREEL,Y,CITTOULNGUS T
BEHA SO DYIN>>UT
OOCTGR  WTH, O MANDCES,NYIEDS AH
EAW TEAD FTHREVETHOMOPOUYBEOU RS
E LYUTT LIDLES,ALHIPUINTO G KOPB
HAH I
PL E E ALESISSERSES,S TET ESUE
I E IRYINEOINEN
WSL
HONWA GH.
WOOS S,EM  TSNDWH SG WTO TH RIT
HITH LGS ANEIOROYA AACSET E KI M
AEE B  TOO FMA TN OONVENHEMO TL
IEES AT NHERKIRLKHTM, A  L  ECO,
INEASN BTHNG O>> I
WND COTHARNG  BUSERYEIR INN OKL
SE TLLD
ESIMDORDEHE IFES
RY SSTEHAMELDEL IB A TS.IVY
S. M T R AGNDYI HVENSG AGRN S GD
ISE IL A,E A
IGSI W, T
TYN TEAIETHPR PLLHIT
ES
A ODE THAYLY
OTET SYERLEREAL  E  POR OOADAIS
NGIM
RY PI ALIINTAIV WOUTHSE AACIN TS
O T SHELSSTESOV
ASS,S PAT  FFOLISININNL, EE W
ALNSK
REOUKN
EWNIO
NSAI T MTHRALMKE IGGEIN K
ERELL TIRT.G RY T>>HA G
NG  IIOT
TR O T FHEAN Y'RUE OCSI EOTETO A
ATDHEEDCOBEINCYOS F P  'M DG TA
WEGEUTFHEACDYRE GGMEATJOON IPLND
Y SON IOTA
HACOENRFO
PRNT O TTH ANNDND